-Our first guests tonight
are the father/son duo
you know from shows
like "9-1-1: Lone Star,"
"The Grinder"
and "The Lowe Files."
They co-created
and star in "Unstable,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Let's talk about us.
-Us?
-I'm worried about us.
-Are we an "us"? I've never
thought of us as an "us."
-Exactly. Since you've been
here, you've made friends.
That's great. But we haven't
spent much time together.
-Mm-hmm.
Because at work, you're my boss.
And at home, you're my dad.
And everybody else is just
a normal friend.
-Yes. So let's go somewhere
where we're not father/son
or boss/employee.
Just friends.
-Oh, my God. Are you going to
make me jump out of an airplane
strapped face-to-face with you
again?
Because that was terrible.
-Well, I loved it.
And I'm the one
who got vomited on.
-Please welcome to the show Rob
and John Owen Lowe, everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show, gentlemen.
This is very exciting for me.
-It's very exciting for me
to sit
in the least important position
in the studio.
-There you go.
-I knew he was going
to say something about this.
-Yeah, he was going to
jump right in.
And I noticed he pointed there.
He wanted you to sit there
and then he was going
to be like, "Woe is me."
-Well, he wanted it
to make it seem like it was
his decision.
-That's exactly right.
-You were going to sit here
no matter what?
-That's what I want
everyone else to know.
But yes.
-So you are --
You are playing father/son
in this show.
You are not playing
this father/son.
But it does seem to be
a heightened version
of your reality.
Is that fair?
-It is. I think that Rob
is dangerously close
to as insane as his character
is on the show.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's -- yeah, it's --
I mean, you want
to defend yourself slightly?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
What happened was John Owen
would troll me mercilessly.
And I think the last time I was
on the show --
-I was going to say we
dove deep into the fact
that you got trolled hard
by John Owen.
-And thank you then
for making this show happen
because it caught on
and people kind of liked it.
And we were like,
"Maybe there's a show there."
And that's how we came up
with the idea.
-And so this premise, again,
you are not Rob Lowe the actor,
and you are not his son,
but you are --
I mean, is it safe
to say -- and again,
correct me
if I offend your father
in any way -- an egomaniac?
Maybe a bit of an egomaniac?
-Yeah. No, I mean, yes. A bit?
Yeah.
I mean, and to be clear,
this is like not a bit.
We leave here and get
in the car together
and it's straight to the car
mirror and like,
"how do I look" and...
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-This is authentic.
-Now, see, I would --
And again, you're going to be
less a part of this.
-Okay.
-Thank God.
[ Laughter ]
-Because I would have thought --
And again, I've met your dad.
Your dad is a very cool person
when you meet him in real life.
And I would have thought
he was a very cool dad.
But based
on your social media,
I've been completely disabused
of that notion.
-First of all,
I'm glad to hear that. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Look, he is cool. I will
begrudgingly admit that --
Well, I don't know about cool,
but he's a good dad.
-He's handsome.
-Yeah, well, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Sure.
He's a good dad.
But he's -- You...
-Yes.
-...are...
-...fairly insane.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, I like to say
a benevolent narcissist, right?
So yes.
-Benevolent.
-Well, now, Rob,
I have to say again,
I have a couple
of boys of my own.
I can't even imagine
how wonderful it must be
to be on set together.
And especially,
I should note as well,
this show has been incredibly
well received so far.
Are you just so happy
and proud every day?
-It's pretty -- It's really
special because, I mean,
you're a generation
behind me with your kids,
but they'll get to a point where
they don't need you anymore
and they're off in their lives
and you have to figure out ways
to spend time with them.
-Yeah.
-And that's what we have done.
-Yes.
-And you obviously must love
your son John because, again,
like I said,
he's been very hard on you.
[ Laughter ]
This is one where
you wrote, Rob,
you wrote "Who wore it best?"
-I thought it was funny.
See, I'm doing
the Angelina Jolie leg.
-And first comment was John here
"Why did you start using
Instagram freely again?
Go back to the podcast posts."
[ Laughter ]
-That was a good one.
I'm proud of that one.
-This is again, this is
all him commenting on you.
So there are you on the boat.
And now again, Rob,
you tried to be funny here.
"Unreal.
This drug-smuggling boat
landed on our beach
in the middle of the night.
Happy Labor Day."
-True.
-John wrote,
"We need to start
teaching our parents
Internet literacy and decorum."
[ Laughter ]
-Can I just quickly
just say that that's real?
That boat washed up
and it was like a crime scene
and he thought
he was important enough
that he could just go there
and start touching things,
like a live crime scene,
and then post about it
on Instagram.
And so it's kind of a bit,
but it's also very real.
-You're trying to like --
It's an intervention of a sort.
-At a certain point
you'd think he'd notice,
but I just get to keep going
because he hasn't noticed yet.
-This is really the best one.
It's the Oscars.
-Yeah.
-You once famously
performed the Oscars.
-Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
-Yeah.
Maybe the kids
don't remember it.
-Well, they will now!
-So you did a song and dance
with Snow White.
-Yes, I did.
-And this is the photo
that John put up that says,
"Congrats to all the Oscar
winners, and to the losers,
you still never did this."
[ Laughter ]
-That -- I was. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That one was mean.
That one maybe was too mean.
-No, I don't think --
Look, I'm good. The meaner,
the better. I can take it.
-You're a good sport.
-Thank you.
-Now, the other thing, though,
is, Rob, is it accurate
that John did not
grow up watching your films?
-Ask him.
-Did you watch any of
your dad's movies?
Oh, no, no, no. Ask him about
your favorite
"West Wing" moment.
-Okay.
What's your favorite "West Wing"
moment?
-I don't have one
'cause I've never seen it.
-You never watched
"The West Wing"?
-I will say this much.
Aaron Sorkin and the rest of the
cast, incredibly talented.
-Okay now.
-I'm sure they're great.
I bet that show is phenomenal,
but I've never seen it.
-He's actually not kidding.
-Now, how does
that make you feel?
-Sad and lonely.
-And lonely.
You would feel
like that either way.
-I guess so
you realize -- And again now,
I don't want to turn this on you
because, you know,
we've talked about your dad's
imperfections a great deal here.
I got to say, John, the fact
that you will only watch
one of your dad's shows
that you're in...
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, I got to be honest,
it's a real, like,
son of Rob Lowe thing to do.
-Look.
[ Laughter ]
That is totally fair.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That's valid. That's valid.
I watched "Parks and Rec."
I watched that
before he went on it and then...
[ Laughter ]
...continued to watch it.
-Oh, that's nice.
-Yes.
-What about on set?
Because you you have
less of a background.
I know you're a writer,
but on camera,
this show was a bit of a --
it's a big deal.
Was it helpful to have your dad
on set as your costar?
-It was.
But he...
He's difficult at times.
I would say that...
There was this one moment --
I'll share this one moment
because it was sweet
but also disturbing,
which was that
the first day of shooting,
it's the first shot
and I'm a little nervous.
I haven't been -- I hadn't had
that much responsibility on set.
And so it's like
I got to get on my mark.
We're about to roll.
And right before we roll,
you started to ramble about
how the mark was wrong
and how someone was going
to cross in front of me
and my hair looked off
and maybe my chin
wasn't chiseled enough
and whatever it was.
[ Laughter ]
And it got me to this place
where I was very frustrated
and very anxious.
And then they called action,
and it was what my character
was supposed to be doing
in that moment.
And I thought to myself
afterwards, I'm like,
"Damn it, did he just, like,
Miyagi me or something?"
[ Laughter ]
But I don't want to give him
that much credit, so...
-Very, very well played, Dad.
Very impressive.
It's a wonderful show.
And it is just so delightful
to see you guys here in person.
Thanks so much
for making the time.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for having us.
-The Lowes, Rob and John Owen,
everybody.
"Unstable" streaming now
on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
Judd Winick.